[Music]
hello uh thanks for having us here and
today we're going to talk a bit about
building and scaling use cases with open
Ai and what this means in terms of
Enterprises working with open to bring
use cases to production and a little
sneak peek into to agents and how we've
seen some of our experience building
these use cases in now agentic workflows
uh in the field so uh on our side um
just a quick introduction into openai
I'm sure folks have probably heard of
open AI but just in terms of how we
operate we have two core engineering
teams we have our research team which is
1,200 researchers that are inventing
these models right we they build and
deploy these foundational models these
kind of come down from the heavens are
apply team
our second engineering team take this
and build it into product so this is
where you see things like Chad GPT you
see things like the API where GPT models
are available and that's where we
actually deploy this finally in the go
to market sense where we take these
products and put it in end user hands
that's kind of where our team comes into
play with go to market where we actually
help get this in the hands of your
Workforce in the hands of your product
and really start to automate these
internal operations and once we finally
deploy these there's kind of this
iterative Loop where we take feedback
from the field to improve our product
directly and then also improve our core
models through this research flywheel so
that's kind of the last step of getting
it back to research so this is typically
how open AI operates um in terms of the
enterprise we see the kind of AI
customer Journey happen typically in
three phases it doesn't have to happen
in sequence in this way but this is what
we usually see is first and foremost
building an AI enabled Workforce this is
getting AI in the hands of your
employees to become AI literate to use
AI every day in their day-to-day work
that's the first and foremost that first
step typically that we see then from
there you typically graduate to towards
automating your AI operations this is
actually more of internal use cases to
building automation or maybe some
co-pilot type use cases into the
workforce then the last step here is
actually infusing AI into end product
this is end user facing so when it comes
to open a eyes product specifically
enabling your Workforce typically starts
with something like chat GPT so this is
our you know first party product to put
in the hands of users to use day in and
day out then when you talk about
automating operations internally you can
do this partially with chat gbt for the
more complex use cases or more more
customization is needed that's where
something like the API comes in and then
finally infusing this into your end user
products is where it's primarily API use
cases but just to give a flavor of how
these products come into play when
actually executing this across your AI
customer
Journey so in terms of how we see
Enterprises actually craft this strategy
in practice it kind of happens in a few
different ways I'd say first and
foremost you determine a little bit from
the top down level of what should the
strategy be and one core thing that we
acknowledge here it's not actually
what's your AI strategy it's actually
what's your broader business strategy
and what open AI does is help figure out
where does a technology meet that
broader business strategy first and
foremost so that kind of top down Str
iic guidance is really important to
start with and then once you start with
that top down guidance you then move to
use cases like let's identify one or two
mey use cases that are high impact to
start with and scope those out to really
just deliver on um kind of that scoped
scale so once you have the strategy you
execute upon those two use one to two
use cases and then you think about how
to build divisional capability across
your Enterprise this is where you start
to enable the team and to fuse AI
throughout the organization and this
happens in many ways this comes through
enablement this comes through building
centers of excellence this comes with
building maybe a centralized
technological platform that other people
in the Enterprise can build on and I
feel like that's typically the journey
we see is again set the strategy pick
those one to two use cases and then
build that capability across your
organization through enablement so
that's usually the the type of Journey
we see and just to illustrate this a
little bit with an
example is this is how we've seen the
use case Journey play out so um this is
illustrative of a three-month type of
example of a use case but when you've
identified that one to two use cases
that you want to tackle first and
foremost you have to ideate upon that do
some initial scoping do some
architecture review to understand how
does AI going to fit into your current
stack and then really clearly Define
what the success metrics and kpis are
once you have that established the bulk
of the time is really spent in
development this is where you iterate
this is where you are iterating
prompting strategies in orating rag
whatever it may be to constantly improve
the uh use case that you're tackling
when it comes to engaging with open a
this is where our team like Brant myself
really interact closely with your
engineering team through things like
workshops things like office hours
paired programming sessions webinars
whatever it kind of takes to accelerate
the use case forward once we do that
development phase we kind of move to
testing and evaluation which is with the
evals we've typically defined upfront
where able to actually now do some AB
testing do some beta roll out to
understand how this actually works at
practice and then finally we go to
production this is where you just do
some launch roll out do some uh scale
optimization testing to make sure it's
going to work once you deploy it to many
end users and then we have kind of
constant maintenance that that's ongoing
so that's like the typical phase you'll
see and again the bulk of the time
especially in partnership with openi
will be around development um in this we
bring a dedicated team we ask you bring
us also a dedicated team to make this
work in practice and the things that we
deploy also to enable you are things
like early access to do models and
features that's one of the key things of
working closely with open AI is that we
can see a little bit into the future not
much like our road map I I don't see
beyond much maybe like six months people
ask what's your 18-month road map I
cannot tell you I can tell you basically
what's going to happen the next two
quarters but that like purview into the
future is really important to bring
forward to these use cases and enable
customers to build and innovate for
what's coming next so that's a really
critical part of our partnership um also
we bring in you know internal experts
from our research engineering team our
product team to help kind of accelerate
you on this path and then lastly just
kind of do joint roadmap sessions to
make sure that we're on track for what
your future road map is as well so
that's hopefully an illustration of how
we partner together and then one
concrete example on this is something we
did with Morgan Stanley so Morgan
Stanley here based in New York uh was
building a internal knowledge assistant
so what this was was giving their wealth
managers the ability to ask questions of
their large corp Corpus of uh knowledge
which was research reports like live
views on stock ticker data whatever it
may be and they wanted to get highly
accurate information back to be able to
respond to their and clients right and
accuracy was pretty bad to start right
it was 45% typically what they saw so
interacting with us we introduced new
methods throughout the use case
development things like hide retrieval
we did some fine tune and vings
different chunking strategies which
improved performance and then once we
kept introducing more and more methods
we saw accuracy go up we introduced
things like reranking and classification
step that got it 85% and ultimately
their goal was 90% we got to 98%
accuracy through other things like
prompt engineering query expansion so
more just an example of how we
introduced methods throughout this use
case journey to uh improve their core
metric for more conly in this case um so
this is hopefully one illustration of
how open eyes partner with customers and
one common use case we're seeing more
and more of is now building in this
agent space you maybe hear that 2025 is
the year of Agents agentic workflows has
been a buzzword for a long time I think
we're seeing that actually come to
reality this year and um I think with
that we've seen uh some B we have some
Battle Scars and some best practices of
what we've seen in the field and I'll
hand it off to pant to talk about what
we've seen on the agent side thanks
DOI so at open ey we were lucky to work
alongside customers who are building
state-of-the-art agents and and working
alongside team members who are building
our own agentic products like deep
research and operator like Doki said we
expect 2025 to be the year of Agents the
year gen gen truly graduates from being
an assistant to being a
cobark and to help usher in this era
we've been hard at work identifying the
patterns and anti-patterns prevalent in
agent development I'm excited to share
four of those with you
today before we can go further further
I'd like to quickly Define uh what we
mean by the term agent so we think of an
agent as an AI application that consists
of a model that has some instructions
usually in the form of a prompt access
to some tools for retrieving information
and interacting with external systems
all encapsulated in in an execution Loop
whose termination is controlled by the
model
itself so one way of thinking about this
is that in each execution cycle the
agent can be thought of as an entity
that's receiving instructions natural
language determining whether or not to
issue any tool calls running those tools
synthesizing a response with the tool
return values and then providing an
answer to the user Additionally the user
may determine sorry the agent May
determine that it's met its objective
and therefore terminate the execution
Loop so with that definition let's move
on to some of the lessons that we've
learned uh building these agents in the
field so for the first Insight imagine
you're designing an AI agent you need to
orchestrate multiple models you need to
retrieve data reason over it and
generate an output you have two choices
you can start with Primitives making raw
API calls logging results your cells um
and logging outputs and
failures or you can start with a
framework you can pick an abstraction
you can wire it up and you can let it
handle a lot of the
details and I have to say starting with
a framework is pretty enticing it's how
I got started building agents it's
really easy to get started have a proof
of concept Concepts stood up in no time
but the problem is that if you start
with a framework you often don't
actually know how your system behaves or
what Primitives it uses you've deferred
design design
decisions before you've understood your
constraints and if you don't know your
constraints you can't optimize your
solution so we believe a better approach
is to First build with Primitives
understand how your task decomposes
where the failures happen
and what actually needs
Improvement then introduce abstraction
when you find that you're Reinventing
the wheel for example by re-implementing
an embedding strategy or reimplementing
model graders that may be a good time to
bring in some
abstractions many teams today are
spending a lot of time picking the right
framework um we actually believe that
developing agents in a scalable way
isn't so much about choosing the right
abstraction it's really about
understanding your data
understanding your failure points and
your
constraints so in summary the first
lesson is to start simple optimize when
needed and Abstract only when it makes
your system
better which leads us straight to our
second inside starting simple so too
often teams are jumping straight into
designing multi-agent systems agents
calling agents coordinating tasks
dynamically reasoning over long
trajectories it all sounds really
powerful but when it's done too soon it
creates a lot of unknowns and it doesn't
give you all that much
Insight we like a different
approach we generally recommend starting
with a single agent that's purpose built
for a single task put that into
production with a limited set of users
and observe how it
performs doing this allows you to
identify the real
bottlenecks hallucinations over
conversation trajectories low adoption
due to high latency or maybe inaccuracy
due to poor retrieval
performance then knowing how the system
underperforms and knowing what's
important to your users we can work to
incrementally improve
it in a nutshell we should think of
complexity as something which increases
as we discover more intense failure
cases and
constraints because the goal isn't
really to build a complicated system
it's just to build a system that
works so starting simple sounds great uh
but we all know that complexity is where
True Value is realized so how should we
handle more complex
tasks this is where a network of agents
and the concept of handoffs comes
in so you can think of
handoffs sorry let's start with the
network of Agents so a network of Agents
is a collaborative system where multiple
agents work in concert to resolve
complex requests or perform a series of
interrelated tasks you can think of this
as a series of specialized agents
handling subflows within a large agentic
workflow on the topic of handoffs you
can think of
these as the process by which one agent
transfers control of a active
conversation to another agent it's
pretty similar to how you get
transferred to someone else on a phone
call except in this case you can
preserve your entire conversation
history and the new agent just magically
knows everything you've talked about
already
so let's see an example of
this in this sample architecture we are
showing how a fully automated customer
service flow may be implemented with a
network of agents and
handoffs this approach is allowing us to
BU bring the right tools to the right
job so for example on the left hand side
we're using a GPD 40 mini call to
perform triage on the incoming request
we're then using GPD 40 on the dispute
agent to actually manage the
conversation with the user and finally
we are using a O3 mini reasoning model
to perform accuracy sensitive tasks like
checking whether the customer is
eligible for
refund it turns out that handoffs work
really well and keeping the entire
conversation history and context while
swapping out the model The Prompt the
tool definitions provide sufficient
flexibility to solve a wide range of
scenarios so our final lesson pertains
to
guardrails and just a level set
guardrails is a catch all term today for
any mechanism that enforces safety
security and reliability within your
application and it's generally used to
prevent misuse and ensure that your
system maintains
Integrity so keeping the model
instructions simple and focused on the
target task ensures maximum
interoperability of your system and also
ensures that we are able to Hill Climb
On on accuracy and performance most uh
predictably guardrails should not
necessarily be made part of your main
prompts but should instead be run in
parallel and the proliferation of faster
and cheaper models like GPD 40 mini is
making that making this more accessible
than ever tool calls and user responses
that are high stakes for example issuing
a refund or showing a user what
information uh some information from
their personal account these can be
deferred until all of the guard rails
have
returned in this example we see that
we're running a single input guardrail
to prevent prompt injection and then a
couple of output guard rails uh on the
use on the agent's
response so to recap we have four
lessons from our time building agents
use abstractions minimally start with a
single agent graduate to a network of
Agents when you have more intense and
finally keep your prompts simple and
focused on the happy path and use guard
rails to handle edge
cases thank you than
[Music]